right good afternoon everyone welcome to
this meeting of cabinets
um
do we have apologies for absent sam
we don't have any apologies as such
except that councillor harvey's not well
so he is here virtually attending but he
will not be taking part in any of the
decisions that are taken today
thank you and so councillor kettle is
going to be a little late thank you
welcome councillor harvey remotely
uh right turning immediately to the
agenda
and i can find it
we've done apologies for absence
disclosures of interest
no
minutes confirm and sign the minutes of
the meeting held on the 7th of march are
there any comments on the minutes
i'll take that as a no so uh
i can confirm unsigned the minister the
meeting is that correct everyone
agreed
fine moving on item four local
development scale scheme
deputy leader place and economy
portfolio council of pemberton
thank you chair and lena um members uh
the item before you uh relates to um
the the adoption of a revised local
development scheme members of cabinet
this is a recommendation to council of
this council that has to make that
decision
as you know the the development scheme
is in essence um the work program that
identifies how and when we're going to
implement documents
papers are straightforward
the timetable the recommendations are
that the timetable for the preparation
of local planned documents that are
outlined be approved and that the
development scheme be revised
accordingly and that the local
development scheme is brought into
effect um in accordance with section 15
bracket 7 close bracket of the planning
and compulsory purchase act 2004
members if
anybody has any
observations questions i'll try and take
those other than that just seeking
seeking confirmation of the
recommendation to council councillor
barker then councillor perry i apologize
for this question i am assuming that
there is no meaning
in the different tones of ink in this
which on your computer might be
different colors
okay
on my computer i'm not seeing anything
because i've only got soft copies of
this but i on that and on that basis i
wouldn't take um anything into that
i presume but
different different colors so whatever
okay i i've done i've i can't pick that
up on my soft copy of packages then
probably on your copy it would imply
there isn't anything in it
council parry
thank you leader i'd just like to second
the recommendation and pass on my thanks
to the policy team
for an excellent
start and progress and it's great to see
that we've got a very solid timetable
coming through thank you councillor
parry
before we move on
i just do have a question
151 council of pemberton
where it says with its focus on reserve
sites it appears to be a relatively
unique plan could you just comment on
that sentence please thank you um uh
that reflects the fact that uh the site
allocations plan is a creature of the
current core strategy and the
examination in uh the examiner in public
sorry the inspector at the examination
in public who for a number of reasons
including the previous housing
moratorium circuit
20056
and an under delivery of uh of housing
on and a concern about our ability to
deliver in accordance with the plan um
set out the site allocations plan as a
mechanism
it is not
a usual or regular part of course
strategies local plans b
it is a creature of
the the the place we found ourselves at
the time of the examination in public
thank you for clarifying that council of
pemberton uh extremely clearly if i may
say so so the recommendations to council
on page five recommendations one and two
are they acceptable to uh cabinet
members of council members of cabinet
thank you
so moving on
item five
tree planting notice of motion
council shenton
thank you leader
i'm not sure oh yeah it's on
i think
sorry councillor junaid
yes um since uh my what i was one of the
people that
that um put my my name to this notice
motion so i don't know whether it would
be useful for me to speak before the
portfolio holder or afterwards um
okay uh please counselor
please just to be just because i need to
put a couple of things straight um it
says in um 1.61 and 1.62 about um
that this motion is about um trees on
district council land and costs being
born by the district council can i make
it quite clear that the motion does not
say
that trees must be on district council
land or owned land or that they must
find the money to plant them at the time
when i moved the motion the what the
woodland trust was running a local
authority campaign
uh and um they are it is now closed uh
but they are now working with 1282
local authorities who all
accepted this kind of wording um and and
are working now with the woodland trust
what the um what the motion is asking
for is for a target to be spe
set and then the powers of the council
to be used to enable
and then external funding to be sought
if appropriate
um there's been a number of people that
have not only the woodland trust but
also friends of the earth have produced
a campaigning uh briefing on what
councils can do
and what they've um
it's clear is that by setting a strong
signal um and the cost across the
country
those that have accepted this motion
include councils of every single uh
political party including the
conservatives i have to say
um so um
they've they've said that uh that one
thing that one way in which for example
you can use that target in a positive
way is for the local plan process um to
to
make it clear as indicated in the nppf
various paragraphs port 14
and
paragraphs
148 169 paragraphs 170 283
so the what it is it was about it was to
try to get the to
enable and support the idea of working
in partnership it was not and never was
about indicating and using council owned
land or the council finding its money
there is now a government scheme or some
several government schemes actually that
has just been announced to help local
councils with these um tree planting and
i know not not only the woodland trust
but other organizations are also
supporting local councils to do that so
could you please take that notice of
motion in the spirit in which it was
originally put forward not in the way
it's been interpreted in these papers
thank you
thank you leader um
i accept
what you're saying counselor junior
however the motion quite clearly says
um talks about setting a target to at
least double double the tree canopy over
a local authority area by 2045
and to include the target in the south
warwickshire local plan um
so
i
i i
i hear what you say is meant to be the
spirit
in the spirit of it but it still talks
about doubling so
i have to say when this was put forward
i was i was very disappointed with this
as i think the cabinet knew and
i still remain of the same opinion i was
disappointed by the motion and i'll go
i'll explain a little bit why
um
my feeling is that
this
is tried to if you like hijack the
agenda a little bit on uh on
on climate change and
um i'm
i think the motion is ill thought out
it's been a waste of officers time
it's been a waste of council tax like
payers hard earned cash put
the money that we've spent on putting
this together and wasteful of the again
of the earth's natural resources because
we put it on paper and the paper where
it's actually destroying trees the very
things we're trying to save here
so my view is very much why is this why
this why wasn't this motion and a
subsequent motion on verges
not bought before the climate change
panel very panel
that
is supposed to discuss these sorts of
things
my feeling
is that this is more about
green washing
and grabbing the headlines than anything
else
i'll go on to talk about this a little
bit more
you know that obviously
by submitting this motion you've got air
time you've got media time
and in the council at today's meeting
and again it'll come up at the future at
the future council meeting
and
as i say this is uh the the the cost of
this has been
they've been uh quite quite high
could you say
could i come into it let me finish
because
this is a democracy and we are
encouraged as councillors to take part
thank you
i still feel
that you
you bought this uh not you personally
but they because it came in the name of
the lib dem party
was a blatant attempt
at
green washing
you set out in the in the paper
the things that you want
section two point moving on to two point
section 2.2
this is the bit i am happy to support
which is
sending a letter to the secretary of
state on funding but again this is
something that could have been done
through the climate change panel it
didn't need to come
to cabinet
because we've done this before sending
letters to the secretary of state
the subsequent sections after this set
out why the motion should be rejected
not least because we set the climate
change action plan and agreed the
the the basis of what we were going to
do in november this this came forward
this motion in december
you yourself sit on this climate change
panel it's the second time now that
you've
bought something via emotion nothing to
do with democracy it's about cost
and
and whether it's climate friendly
the
climate change panel sits without
minutes without a paper we sit
remotely apart from you and i come in
here you come in because you you've been
using in town i come in here just in
case there are
members of the public here everybody
else sits remotely so we don't waste
time
increase co2 emissions by bringing
people in
we don't even publish
this
we make people print it or read it
online
so
i think
myself i think this could have been done
better through the climate change panel
the cost of what you're saying
as the paper points out an eye watering
350 to 4 million pounds
to do what what you want what you would
like to do
and just to put this into some context
in doubling the
the canopy cover across stratford 8 000
hectares is approximately 31 square
miles so that's the equivalent of a one
mile wide forest stretching 30 miles
across land we don't own
across land that's productive in food
terms
it's also the equivalent of roughly 60
000 olympic sized swimming pools
of 10 000 football pitches the size of
the west bromwich albion pitch i
actually measured this one against the
manchester city
pitch but we don't have any man city
supporters as far as i'm aware of here
but there's 10 000 pitches it's bigger
than the city of wolverhampton and it's
50 percent bigger than the area of loch
ness
that's the scale of what you're asking
i don't think this is practical and
reasonable or feasible
by now you've probably got the picture
that i feel that the recommendation to
council should be supported in section
as laid out in section 1.6.4
and laid out in section 2.2 i.e
to partially support the motion only in
terms of writing to the secretary of
state
i challenge you
the journey
to recognize this is a more sensible way
forward
but i
almost
i predict that when we get to council
with this that the lib dems will
abstain as normal on these matters
a green washing yet again
thank you leader for letting me get this
off my chest you know this has been
bubbling away inside me for about five
months now four months since it came
forward i am not happy with it and i
will only support and recommend
the less letter of the letter to the
secretary of state
i think your views have been extremely
clearly expressed councillor shenton
councillor pemberton
so what this motion has been
spectacularly successful at doing when
following hot on the heels of the grass
verges motion
is to turn
the portfolio holder for climate change
from
being someone open to embracing
a wide range of discussions
enabling
lots of interaction and actively buying
into different ideas
to someone who's now suspicious of
what's been brought forward and that is
a dreadful place for us to be
the climate is not a party political
issue
you know i've said before people will be
dragged kicking and screaming to this
whether they be conservatives labor
voters liberal democrat voters green
voters it doesn't matter who you are
um
councillor schenton is absolutely right
now councillor junior tells us that a
number of other authorities have
considered that this type of motion what
we don't know is how many of them have
taken that step having taken it through
their own internal equivalence the
climate change panel and actually done
the hard thinking around
how is
an expansion of the tree canopy which at
a very top-line level
is something
to be thought of as positive and to be
supported but to hone that down to
something that is can be achievable and
can deliver appropriately um and talk
about you know the safe workshop plan
well the climate change
of the south warwickshire plan
and i share councillor shenton's
disappointment
um
as we move through this thing almost
every other week there is going to be
something there's going to be a report
there's going to be do this this will be
do that
and if we move to a position where we
react only through
the blunt and inefficient
but
publicity friendly
vehicle of cancel motions
then we are we are we are we are at this
it is creating a disservice to our
residents because we're not actually
then trying to address the issue um and
i'm going to look towards
mr grafton to get his thinking cap on
because frankly i'd like to see a
position where the default for anything
around climate change must go through
the panel first from here on in we have
a we have a broad range of people and
councillor junior you have seen me uh
you know actively reach out and agree
different things that yourself and
councillor pertiguella have brought to
the table because when there's a smart
idea about the climate we we need to
adopt it
um but i am you know again i i i mean
i'm beginning to be in the same place as
councillor shenton you know with a heavy
heart i'm just starting to think well
we're just getting a kick in here for no
reason and it's just about it's just
about the next focus i'm sorry if you
disagree with that because i know you're
passionate about about climate change
counselors unit but you're going about
this the wrong way um so i am actually
going to ask um that we try and see if
there's some mechanism we can agree
whereby
anything related to this this matter
from here on gets to the climate change
panel it's almost like some the
equivalent of an automatic referral to
osc so that we can have
proper scrutiny and not sorry that's a
proper debate and get some really
smart things out of it so that's it for
my two pennies worth and yeah i shared
the councillor shenton's disappointment
thank you councillor pemberton
it's quite interesting what you said
about debate
because
i must admit when i read this
i have some concerns about the sheer
scale
of the tree planting that's been
considered
and in particular given what's happened
lately with
an increased focus on security food
supply
this i think was coming
anyway because of
prior to the war in ukraine
but if you look at what's beginning to
happen to food supply
i mean
the planet is getting hotter and it's
going to continue getting hotter that
actually reduces crop yields
uh grain yields in russia i think it was
last year because it was a hot year
we're down 30
that is really significant
we are mining out aquifers and aquifers
are needed to do an awful lot of the
irrigation of agricultural land that
again
is going to reduce food supply
if you look at what's happening in the
mountains
snow cover
is decreasing
glaciers are retreating
that actually means snow and glacier
melt is not available for irrigation in
spring and summer
we are going to have more droughts and
more floods which again is going to
reduce food supply
sea levels are rising
i see at long last we're beginning to
take seriously the fact that sea levels
could rise a meter this year that's
going to impact on food supply and we've
still got increasing population
i think one of the real issues is it's
all right to talk about planting trees
to offset climate change
but that's got to be balanced against
the other things that land can be used
for
noticeably growing food
i think
that on issues like this there really
does need to be far more debate and far
more informed discussion because at the
moment if i'm really honest about it my
sense is
this is far too one-dimensional and far
too simplistic
and i would actually concur
with exactly what councillor shenton
said
that the notice of motion relating to
tree planting is rejected
but we do
write to the secretary of state to
request more funding for trees
mr grafton
i must i must
just make the point that
our constitution
says that any member of the council can
place
notice of motion
on the table
if the matter concerns the
responsibility of the council or if if
it affects the council in some way so so
my role in the and the chief executive
as well is to to vet
motions on notice on that basis and if
they meet the criteria then they can
come through a full council meeting
thank you for clarifying that mr grafton
councilman pemberton do you want to
respond thank you yeah i i yeah i think
it it would indeed
entail some um
amendment to the constitution so that
there's a you know if if nothing else
there is you know uh in addition to the
options available you know to to to
actually route these kind of things to
the climate change panel at the end of
the day we have set the climate change
panel as our sort of you know the these
are the members with ownership and you
know they they're
they should help inform and i think
i i if i take a look around the table
i'm not sure i would see much argument
from cabinet about that as a way of
informing decisions uh for both cabinet
and to come back to to cancel i i i i
could understand it could be in the
semi-difficult box but all the plea is
only for for us to put our thinking caps
on about what a solution might look like
but noting where we are with the
constitution at the moment thank you
thank you councillor pemberton i i think
bearing in mind what mr grafton's said
we've got to be very careful
not to restrict the ability of
counsellors to actually put forward and
notice his emotion on matters of
interest
bearing that in mind i think the debate
on where things should be rooted has
been very intric very interesting and
very useful
so with that uh
can
our members of council cabinet surrey
councillor junior yes i i i thank you
for recognising that that because um
when counselor jennifer actually wanted
to put this on and i seconded it
i did recognize and she i recognized
that counsellors do she has a genuine
interest and at the time it was a
campaign that was being run by the
woodland trust
which
has worked was working across the
country to get local authorities
involved in tree planting and run a
scheme a funding scheme which you say
the local authority
tree pla escapes fund for example uh was
one that they were working on so i i
recognize that councillors in a
democracy do have the ability and should
have the ability to raise things that
are of their interest and to be treated
uh with dignity and um and recognition
that they they have they are they are
genuine this is this was a genuine um
case of trying to see whether we could
get a debate started and a genuine
discussion to make sure that we could we
were in a position not only in the local
plan but to in order to be able to put
plans forward a business plan forward so
should there be um funds available from
government and from other sources that
we would be prepared thank you very much
indeed for listening to me
thank you councillor junior councillor
barker
um i'd just like to um remind everybody
that very very shortly after i joined
cabinet my view of health and well-being
was that planting trees was a really
really good idea
and i came up with the quidditch tree
scheme so this is nothing new and mine
was cheaper
thank you council of markets so
members of cabinet
council shenton
yeah just to add to the final bit to
this is what we should also remember is
that we are bringing forward a tree
planting
proposal
into the may cabinet
and it was
highlighted in when we talked about the
climate change action plan back in
november
so
there was no reason to bring this motion
forward at all because we'd already got
it under consideration
all i'm asking for is courtesy
that when these sort of this is not the
first one
it's not even the second one has been a
few of these the courtesy of running
them through the climate change panel
and letting the panel at least debate it
first
thank you councillor shenton so your
recommendation to council
that the notice of motion relating to
tree planting is rejected but that we do
write to the secretary of state
members of cabinet are you supportive of
that
agreed thank you members of cabinet so
moving on
sorry the assessment of land parcels
which adjacent to the kosovo national
landscape council of pemberton
thank you members of cabinet um this
report is in relation to a piece of
technical evidence that we need to
uh gather and accept and use uh to
ensure that we've got a robust evidence
base uh when considering any aspects of
development and this particular piece of
work is the an assessment of land
adjacent to and how we would treat land
adjacent to the cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty
and just to clarify this is uh not how
land uh in the district within the aomb
will be treated um uh members uh i am
comfortable as portfolio holder that it
is a a robust piece of evidence and
should be accepted in uh
at this point so the recommendation is
the the report on the landscape
sensitivity assessment of the land
parcels adjacent to the cotswolds
national landscape be received and used
to inform plan making including the
preparation of the site allocations plan
uh i'm looking for a seconder on that or
i but we'll take any questions of course
thank you
yes
well done thank you councillor paris
seconded any comments observations
council parry i i would just like to say
that i think this is a a really well
put together robust
piece of evidence that will be
particularly valuable to the planning
team the policy team in the local plan
making but also will help those parishes
that are included
in this report
giving greater clarity on the scenario
so i have great pleasure in seconding
the recommendation
thank you councillor parry you make some
excellent points so with that
um we've had the recommendation on page
23 proposed and seconded
our cabinet members in favor of that
recommendation please
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on item seven uh tradition neighborhood
development plan
and once again it's councillor pemberton
uh thank you chair and leader um the
treadington neighborhood development
plan has now reached its pre-submission
consultation stage um which provides
that as the district council and local
planning authority we provide a response
to the regulation 14 pre-submission
consultation um i would like to thank
the treadington neighborhood development
plan for their sterling work in bringing
their ndp to this point
and to also particularly thank members
of the policy team
who work
diligently and closely with communities
in support in the preparation of their
neighborhood development plans
members of cabinet the the
comments made are set out uh as part of
our response are set out in appendix one
um in order to support the uh parish
council and ndp group in moving their
plan for forward so members of cabinets
uh the recommendation is that the
schedule of significant comments which
are appendix one being endorsed and
submitted to treadington parish council
as the formal response to the
pre-submission consultation process
associated with the draft treadington
neighborhood development plan provided
at appendix 2. um clearly again we'll
take any questions
but other than that seek support for the
recommendation thank you thank you
councillor pemberton councillor harvey
this is your award and i'm sure that
remotely you would like to make some
comments
uh can you hear me
you can hear me excellent we can hear
you trevor
uh i'd like to uh endorse what uh
councillor pemberton has said this uh
this is a long
hard task for a few volunteers down in
treadington and newbold and uh in
particular i'd like to pay tribute to
um nigel willis
and john gimblet um john giblet in
particular who has been has taken the
burden of producing most of the written
work associated with the the ndp
um
uh i know that they are grateful to the
to the officers for the comments they
have made
i don't regard any of these as
road breakers
they are all resolvable and uh i'm sure
that uh john and nigel between them are
looking forward to dealing with them um
i hope that we can sort this out to the
point where we can go to referendum next
and hopefully have this matter concluded
before the end of the year
i endorse what's going on and you will
be
pleasantly surprised not
to know that i have provided john gimlet
with a revised copy of his document
which um i have done my usual red
marking including putting the
full stops where they ought to go where
a footnote is concerned
um
uh he's very appreciative i think
um on that basis i'm i'm delighted to uh
if i can support this uh this uh
motion and urge other members of the
cabinet to endorse the recommendation
please
thank you councillor harvey
uh do i have a second for council of
pemberton's proposal councillor shenton
uh
members of cabinet are you supportive of
the recommendation on page 27.
thank you members of cabinet
so item 8
heart shared service partnership
councillor barker
sorry those in in cabinet who were at
cabinet forum um forgive me but i hadn't
actually received the papers at the
point that uh we had a cabinet forum but
a robust debate
took place at cabinet forum anyway which
i am hoping council of pemberton is not
necessarily going to be rehearsed today
but we shall see
um heart has been a service which um
has had some difficulties because it is
delivered um by one district council on
behalf of all the district councils
across the county
as is part of our duty and i just want
to
i always think of heart as heart but it
is the home environment assessment and
response team
just put in contact so you're not just
thinking of heart all the time and they
deliver the disabled facilities grants
um
and one of the major problems as
highlighted by councillor pemberton so
we don't seem to do it very fast
um and i would um wholeheartedly agree
with that but
i would put to you the uh
recommendations on page 37
which seemed very long and i'm not going
to read them
but that we do continue to essentially
to support the heart board
in getting on with sorting out the
trouble that they're having with it
speeding it up and that we
um i think we endorse it for another 12
we have a 12 break clause essentially in
it
but the partnership which does
definitely appear to be working better
than it was
um
particularly
with uh the new
i'm trying to remember who it is who's
new who's been brought in but the board
seemed to be doing a better job of it
over
overview um
if we were going to start again we
probably wouldn't start from here but
this is what we've got it's not exactly
a re-endorsement from me i know but
i would just ask that you approve these
recommendations to council where we will
no doubt have a very robust debate all
right i've got councillor pemberton
councillor junior councillor o'donnell
council councillor pemberton briefly
please thank you um thank you chair and
leader i have no intention of rehearsing
the uh the discussion and the debate we
had at cabinet forum um i i think where
i am is up is quite clear i'm quite
content to
second the recommendations um
i i i would ask that
we are quite all over this like a rash
um and that we're sort of
we we ensure that the heart board does
deliver on its commitments
it is important to some of the most
vulnerable in society that we do so and
do so efficiently that i will leave it
with the
seconding of the recommendations thank
you councillor junior can i thank
councillor pemberton for that and
reassure him that i'll put my bother
boots on now that we're out of kovid
largely
thank you uh we had um and uh councillor
o'donnell will outline what what what
the discussion that took place at the
ovion scrutiny committee but just can i
remind you that um the heart service is
still taking 145 days in south
warwickshire from inquiry to adaptation
and that's from the board's report
and demand is rising and it's not being
effectively managed according to
again to that board report is taking 56
days to waiting for an assessment
so if we proceed could i ask and i'm
sure this is what um was is the
intention um that it must be on that
basis of being uh reviewed and and
looked at through this trans transit
transitional
year we must get a better service
because we're getting a ride with the
demographics we're getting a rising
number of people who need these services
so it is on that basis and i'm sure uh
councillor o'donnell will reflect that
in the report that came from the ovum
scrutiny committee
thank you councillor junior councillor
o'donnell thank you chair um so really
picking up from councillor june has said
and in no way were we critical of nick
cadd's um commitment you know he is
fantastic we felt he was really
struggling with getting the support of
the board and we're um we were grateful
to understand that councillor barker you
are being highly visible in your support
of him and trying to really just push
this through
and one of the comments was if we spend
all the money once there's nothing left
well unfortunately with our most
vulnerable people we need our
adaptations asap
in order to have a good standard of life
we were not satisfied with the delay
there was a strict timeline laid out and
it seemed that nick's work was done but
the board were not supportive in getting
this through so we were not satisfied
with that
um and the delay in reporting from heart
was just in our view not acceptable we
were keen to stress that the progress of
heart should be regularly reviewed and
the option of leaving the partnership
should remain open if no improvement was
seen over the next 12 months we were
looking on page 41 at option two and we
want it brought back to over scrutiny
before the final decision is made
because we felt that nick seemed to be
alone voice really and had an awful lot
of people he was trying to bring with
him which we felt when we're dealing
with the most vulnerable people simply
wasn't good enough
so that it was a pretty robust
discussion at osc and we were very very
concerned
i think there is a pretty unanimous
support for that position councillor
o'donnell and i notice on the
recommendations that uh one b
um
that
22-23 is a transitional year
and in that transitional year
heart had better be seen to be
delivering so with that i've had the
proposal
i've had the recommendations on page 37
proposed and seconded can i have your
agreement bearing in mind that we really
do want this service to function
properly
are you in favor members of cabinet
agreed thank you sir moving on
to
item nine once again this is you
councillor barker
sorry when um when the two
uh district council started um coming
together
it was clear that we in stratfor had a
different
approach to safeguarding
to warwick for the simple reason that we
didn't have responsibility
for housing
and
therefore didn't have the ongoing
responsibility for adults
children various other procedures
related to having housing stock
however
i'm delighted with the new strategy
because
it is
definitely putting safeguarding front
and center for all of us it should be
something that we all
have in mind um and the best way to
describe what you should have
and what you should be thinking in terms
of safeguarding is
a professional
curiosity and if something
doesn't seem right
then it might not be and that's where
we all have a responsibility for
safeguarding i'm sure many councillors
around this table
deal with
safeguarding um on an almost weekly
basis with many of their residents um
and so i'm just delighted that we've
we've actually beefed things up and got
a proper
safeguarding policy here so
the recommendations
are that we approve the joint
safeguarding policy procedures etc
and we agree that any minor changes in
the future
can be um done by the strategic lead
safeguarding officer
include
in consultation with those of us who are
champions for safeguarding
i hope that's acceptable i think it's a
i think it's a really robust piece of
work and i'm very grateful for it
oh and one addition needs to be made i
noticed that my phone number is never
provided on here and everybody else's
phone numbers are given how many
safeguarding things i actually deal with
personally my phone number might as well
be on
counselor
uh it's just a quick query but with the
um the homes for for ukraine scheme that
the government is running will this team
uh and this process be um
you know be used by the by in that pro
in that
scheme at all do you know
okay i mean chairman
the home studio ukraine scheme we're
working very closely with the county
council on the arrangements to
you know uh welcome ukrainian families
to to the area and please don't know
we're gonna have five families moving
into the the district very soon um these
these policies will go across all
sectors whether they're refugees or
whether they're their residents to the
council thank you
um and indeed i had a conversation today
with mr platts where we briefly touched
on what was being done and you know the
the how homes and things that have been
checked out
um and the people who have been looked
at so i'm encouraged that yeah we are
absolutely on top of it
thank you councillor mark has proposed
the recommendations on page 57 can i
have a secondary please
council pemberton thank you
our members of cabinet in favor of the
recommendations on page 57
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on item 10
uh councillor barca again
and the recommendations here are that
the report be noted councillor barker
this
um
action plan covers from well last year
to 2026 and is one of those things that
we do keep looking at continually
revising
all that we need to do is to note the
report and the revised action plan
milestones which are
from page
93 onwards
uh
which
are pretty they're pretty they're
totally self-explanatory i don't really
want to read through them because
there's so much to it but
they're good milestones for us to hold
ourselves to we need to remember that we
are attempting to build sustainable
homes and communities
house people so they can live
independently which feeds into what
we're talking about with heart as well
and to prevent homelessness and reduce
the harm caused by it i've note that
homelessness is rising
because significantly at the moment i
couldn't comment on that whether it in
this particular district but it
certainly is rising um
and so of course one of the things we've
done about that is the fred winter
center which will shortly be
accommodating plenty of people
so with that can we please uh
note the report
council shenton
thank you leader um
ambilatedly i think i should declare an
interest in this possibly in this item
so i won't take any part in the vote
if i'm looking over towards the
monitoring office is that correct
procedure
well yes if you've got an interest and
you feel you can't take part just be
noted in the minutes
thank you councillor schenten
anyone else have any comments or
observations
counselor junior
i'm not sure whether council or donald
will pick this up but we at the um
at the um ovian scrutiny committee a
comment was raised about the rural
housing enabler role which
is only funded i think for one more year
i think
and the question was raised about that
because that's a very valuable role for
providing affordable housing in rural
areas in particular if i may just pick
up on that thank you council tuna i was
just about to make that point um no it's
fine it's just that this this came
through
around the discussion with renato on the
sustainable home sustainable communities
housing strategy because it was felt
that if we're looking towards joint
working or a merger there is a fear that
the rural voice is being lost and
therefore to not have the um funding for
sarah brook taylor's role
guaranteed was of concern especially to
those of us who represent rural
communities
so um it was felt that we really did
want to know that that was a safe role
and we weren't sure how to go about
ensuring that was
demarcated in the um
as we move forward
councilor barker do you want to respond
um it's my understanding that this is
rolling
um and that that should not be an issue
but i may be wrong perhaps perhaps mr
buckland would like to answer everyone
chairman thank you enough i believe this
is you came up during the budget setting
process uh for 22 23 the role is funded
for this particular year and i think the
the the the way forward was that it was
going to be considered as part of the
budget setting process for the year 23
24.
excuse me i described that as rolling
sorry yes
i think we were just fearful that it's
to be discussed it's not guaranteed so i
think that's what came through at the
committee was that people were concerned
that it wasn't a guaranteed role because
she does the most phenomenal work um you
know i'm sure you've seen her in action
at the parish councils so we were
concerned it wasn't guaranteed it was
going to be reviewed
i don't think that we can fetter the
next budget that's the problem
but as you know it'll be another thing i
put my bother boots on about because you
know that
you know the parishes i sit in where if
we didn't have a rural housing enabler i
would get a serious kicking there's some
very busy bother bits going on i think
mr grafton
um
probably a little bit behind the wave
here but just to remind people that if
we're discussing
matters that impinge on an individual
then we should
go into private and confidential to
discuss that because it's it's what we
call exempt information but
i've left it because
you weren't quite there but you write on
the fringes of it okay in in that case i
think the points being made the points
being recognized
so uh
the recommendations on page 87
uh council bach has proposed it can have
a second to place council of pemberton
cabinet members in favor please
agreed thank you
so moving on
reports from cabinet committees oh sorry
issues from arising from overview and
scrutiny we've already considered at
least two of them council o'donnell
there was just one further piece of
feedback really that we had a really um
in-depth and and interesting update from
the police and crime commissioner it was
a really valuable visit from the q a
over an hour and a half and um some of
our um takeouts from that was that six
county lines have recently been
disrupted
um that there was a huge amount of small
grants going towards some domestic abuse
um with regards to families and victims
and it was just really to reiterate how
valuable valuable it was to have that
in-person q a
and we thought it was a very positive
discussion as i say and previously we've
gone through the heart and we've also
gone through sustainable homes so that's
all that really came up at that meeting
thank you councillor o'donnell
uh no reports from cabinet committees
the unblock items
uh
considered climate change panel minutes
and stratford-upon-avon markets for
minutes uh we do have an item of urgent
business which councillor barker
referred to me uh earlier councillor
barker
it's not that exciting
um it may have come to your attention
that i rarely receive post
i
made some investigations into why i and
others rarely receive post
and
was told that there are areas of the
district
which do not have
post office postman on their routes so
my house in particular
and others which i have found out
subsequently
didn't have a postman actually serving
it
so from a personal point of view i went
and fixed that by talking to someone and
pleading to be added to a route
however this raised with me the fact
that
uh i get a bit fed up but not really my
getting the right paperwork but
obviously
notices legal papers council tax bills
they're green bin stickers for instance
if they don't get post and i know that
in shipston
um a couple of the new estates are not
receiving post more than once every few
weeks
and that's because it's done as an extra
round
so what i would ask is that the chief
executive or whoever else would like to
write the letter
there you go rights to royal mail asking
how they are actually
managing their remit when we know that
they are not
delivering post equitably across our
district
thank you councillor barker council
o'donnell
can i just actually can um support what
council barca says this is brought up at
um eddington parish council it looks um
it's been happening in loxley it's
brought in pillorton um and also in
fulford that often people are missing
hospital appointments it's actually been
a concern that is raised and i know it's
also happening with the cotswold council
as well that a lot of the rural routes
are not being served um efficiently
often we get too weak sometimes in that
post we did
yeah so they're missing vital pieces of
information yeah thank you councilman
o'donnell mr brooklyn
thank you leader
um you really yeah you know i i i
i i i would appreciate a conversation
with councillor barker outside the
meeting then we'll agree the best way to
take that forward um i do accept that as
an authority we rely on the delivery
from oil mail for the delivery of our
services and and therefore there is an
impact for for the district council on
that i question whether a letter might
be appropriate because they might not
receive it themselves um but but we can
work out the best way of of
communicating there thank you mr buckley
i'm informed if it goes special delivery
then it does get there
yes i know the reason why it's raised is
because we do depend so much on the mail
councillor harvard used to interject
uh thank you um i just like to make
people aware that this is i'm not not
unique this is something i've already
raised
uh last week uh with
uh tony perks
and he has uh deputed simon perfield to
deal with it and what simon has done
i think he's done it actually today
has sent an email to to all parish and
town
clerks
asking for their experience
so that
he can have a dossier of
data and anecdotal information which
will serve as an informed basis
to an approach to the royal mail setting
out the basis of our concerns and and
asking them what they're going to do
about it the
the rumor from ships than that i have
had put to me is that there are 12
vacancies not only are there 12
vacancies but for postman
sorry trevor you're freezing
um and there is a there is a route
already being taken and whatever else
action uh mr buckland would like to take
i don't encourage him to do so he might
like to talk to zion
i i think we've got the gist of what uh
councillor harvey was saying it looks as
though
action is in progress
but i would just reiterate what was said
the reason for raising this is
because we do use the royal mail an
awful lot to communicate with our
residents and it is important we can
rely on the service
okay
so with that
meeting closed
you